although sometimes you know when you get
yourself in trouble and then it takes
armor to get into win you end up really
carrying that momentum so we'll see how
neuterbeck is ultimately we'll get to
that in a minute because the first of
our uh of our winners bracket battles
look at this playing fast
playing on prep no more A6 from Magnus
Carlson yeah we didn't he can get away
with it against this guy but we get such
a cool opening
and more importantly none of the rosly
more that we saw in the world
championship match between these two in
a sicilian for a moment there I thought
Fabi was extremely still on the camera
but good to know that everything's fine
the camera is working and uh G4 on the
board David yep G4 for the score as they
say uh very aggressive play from Fabiano
throwing all pawns forward now on the
king side just preempting uh a decision
by the black king now Black's King
should not ever get attempted to Castle
kingside because it's going to be
walking straight into an attack but we
didn't necessarily see this time on off
Paulson system we saw a lot of special
cough he he you know MBL avoids the
night or against Fabiano that should
tell you right and MBL doesn't avoid the
night off against anybody so this is
gonna be awesome to see Magnus played H6
which was the first move that kind of
threw Fabi off before he remembered his
prep prepared player in the world now
apparently that Crown belongs to Anish
giri according to Hikaru you gain one or
two sometimes three moves even for the
sacrifice material and here white as we
see nice safe on C1 and white piece is
looking very active it looks like you've
got some Pawn breaks as well it's it's
could well just really come to life it's
already a life and the other thing is
like you know Magnus historically didn't
really play like this right he's only
started to play like this when he's
maybe not you know holding on to that
world championship title as much he's
playing a lot Freer he always used to
play quite safe not taking too many
risks but this is a incredibly risky way
to play right this this kind of setup a
play like Magnus Carlson you want to get
him into that Mikhail Deep Dark Forest
of complications early on where the part
is narrow enough for just one player to
get out is that the kind of position
that you should be aiming for against
Magnus uh Tanya you mentioned taking him
into a deep dark Forest I mean Jordan
tried that yesterday he took him into a
deep dark van for us but it didn't work
so LOL yeah right now this one is a
complicated position and Danny you're
right these days he kind of relies on
opening preparation more computers more
and he has a great team around him of
course Magnus he said recently in a
training camp that uh now more than ever
has he relied on these sharp variations
because that's the only way to do it
it's up to Fabi to prove the
compensation yeah I mean I I think it's
a great thing that he's done in general
I mean if you look at all the players I
mean I've just taken players who play a
lot of Chess on the British circuit who
may be getting a bit older and they just
play the same chess all the time looks
quite stable for now but uh knowing
Magnus I've seen him in similar
positions drop his Knight back and uh
try to bring it round to a nice outpost
on F5 a bit later on it looks like
you're taking Liberties you're
undeveloping your pieces but actually
this Black Brook is pretty much
developed anyway on an open file this
bishop can come out later and if white
doesn't strike now then you will bring
your knight to a better Outpost later uh
well you know that last one but look at
this what's happening here this is this
is completely Bonkers as well right
completely mad just a weird position
white is down a whole pawn and still has
the luxury to slow play it there is a
battery on the C file and C2 is hanging
with checks so when you kind of laugh in
the face of danger we should show what's
going on with Rook takes F4 deflecting
the queen queen takes C2 check but it's
one of those funny Sicilian positions
where you gotta calculate to the end
because just because you get a scary
check may not actually mean you have
anything left in the tank and this is
reminiscent of a lot of night or type
positions white is actually happy here
of the exchange it it does now yeah I
mean I I don't think white has managed
to generate enough threats in the
position I mean how does white even
generate a fret in this position and if
black can get his 9 and Bishop into the
game okay his King's always going to be
in the middle but it doesn't seem to be
in too much trouble there Black's got
enough counter play against White's King
as well so this is uh this is starting
like I feel to go in magnus's favor
but uh yeah if you survive unfortunately
white just can't get the Knight out of
the way quickly enough yeah Magnus might
be both well that's true and your call
on the board Danny Knight to D3 I think
the only safe way to uh kind of uh stop
95 might be to play Bishop to D6 plays
the right way we think maybe take you on
F3 then he keeps the advantage but it
will take notes of steal and okay he
Dodges any complications he plays Bishop
to D6 and I think Danny your move might
well just appear on the board utilize
that it doesn't work thank you oh Queen
D1 I forgot C2 is hanging at the end
yeah counter attack okay so so maybe in
this position at least you've created
this pin maybe you can uh go for the
Slow Burn attack I don't quite see it
yet
how to break through what a weird
position weird weird stuff complicated
stuff and here at least you haven't
maybe tricks Danny and again it's so
easy looking at his positions with the
evaluation bar but it's not easy but it
it makes it you get an indication when a
move goes wrong but imagine you're
sitting there trying to calculate these
out you don't know if the moves good or
bad are set by calculator it brings in a
whole different dimension and uh you
know this is it's an incredible position
he's under four minutes right now though
and it feels like he's been making one
accurate move after another but it's so
complicated magnus's King is still in
the center the players have no idea
about the eval bar they don't know who's
winning who's better who's not I guess
I'm I'm having a hard time seeing
threats for white that's my problem you
know what really kills me is that nine
on F5 that Knight on F5 is guarding and
controlling everything it is a pain and
you know what I think as David says it
this is Misty this is a stallion on the
board right now that night on F5 not
only a great defensive piece but also an
attacking piece controlling so many
squares and Fabi trying to create
threats here it's exactly what he's
doing touching the one minute Mark any
chances so far be here it's one of the
positions that's even worse than the
math says it is because white has no
threats here The Rook on bh4 guards B4
the queen is guarding everything I'm
like what is Fabi gonna do now he's
under I guess he's he's under a minute
the one thing I would do here I mean
Magnus he'll find us more sophisticated
uh move for sure but the one thing I
would do is just defend everything just
put a rook on C6 and say you shall not
pass and just cover all of these pawns
and uh I don't see anything ever going
wrong there but he finds a maybe even
stronger move trying to force those
Rooks off the board Simon you said any
trades help and that seems to be the
case and unfortunately it's hard to keep
this Rook on the board because if you
slide it across attack that black queen
the other move you mentioned now a queen
trade is guaranteed and that will end
the game two extra points for black yeah
okay he plays Rook H2 at least the White
Queen has more squares to flee to if you
try to trade off now that's desperation
of course the mouth slips there's other
ways that Fabi can get back into this
game and okay D5 looks fine planting a
Pawn on a very safe Square still lacking
ideas here for Fabi to break through
that White Queen it just needs to land
somewhere on the queen side somewhere
Behind Enemy Lines to give black a check
but still how to break through that I
think D5 has a concrete thread he wants
to play 93 and Bobby didn't stop it
because the Knight was guarding D6 and
so now you can go to E3 without Queen
taking which Forks the D1 rook and the
C2 Pawn it's funny he didn't look strong
maybe he'll land it now you couldn't
even take that pawn with a bishop
because Rook D4 was just game over
immediately so uh you know he he's he's
dropping there we go like I dropped ELO
points and uh and they're looking
finishing it off in style takes C2
too many tempting options aren't there I
mean like you can probably resigned what
a finish and with that Fabiano Carolina
goes down in game one